Xcode is a very powerful integrated
development environment and
it may feel a bit overwhelming at first.
That's okay.
Let me show you one of the features of
the interface builder part of Xcode.
That'll make your life a little easier.
It's called the document outline.
Here, I'm looking at
the completed pitch perfect.
Just so you can see
the document outline in full.
Your pitch perfect cap won't have
any of these UI elements just yet.
Here, I have Xcode open to
the main.story board file.
And the document outline is not visible.
See this little button here?
This is what shows or
hides the document outline.
Clicking on it causes
a document outline to open.
In this document outline, we can see
our record sounds view controller.
The view and
all of the UI elements inside that view.
Sometimes you may need to click
on this disclosure triangle
to see the items inside of it.
If you're looking for
an easy way to find and
work with your ui elements,
the document outline is the place to go.
This is especially true once your
app starts to have more than
just a few buttons and labels.